We're now going to
explore one of the most
fundamental reactions
in organic chemistry.
And first, let's
look at what are
the things that
are going to react.
So over here, I have
a hydroxide anion.
It has a negative 1 charge.
And that negative 1
charge comes from the fact
that oxygen is neutral if
has six valence electrons.
But this has one, two,
three, four, five,
six, plus half of this
bond with hydrogen.
So you could think of
that as another electron.
Or it's got half of
these two, so that's
another electron, which
gives it a negative 1 charge.
Now, this right over
here, it has one carbon--
I guess that you could
say-- in its backbone.
It's a methane.
And it has a group right over
here consisting of bromine.
So this is bromomethane.
So let's think a
little bit about what
might happen under
the right conditions.
So this hydroxide anion-- we've
already gone over the fact--
that you could kind
of view it as having
an extra electron, which
gives us this negative charge.
Well, if you have a negative
charged anion-- like this--
it will be attracted
to positive things.
And one example of a
positive thing is a nucleus.
And so in this
reaction, we are going
to refer to this hydroxide
anion as the nucleophile.
Phile literally refers to
things that something likes.
This thing, it's
a nucleus-lover,
I guess you could say.
And so it might want to share
maybe a pair of electrons
with a nucleus.
Now, over here, I
have this bromo group
in the bromomethane.
And bromine is quite
electronegative.
It is more electronegative
than carbon.
So even in this bond,
we have two electrons
in this bond right over here.
Bromine is going to hog the
electrons a little bit more
than carbon.
And also, electronegativity
says that, if this bond were
to break, it's more likely that
this pair-- the pair that's
in this bond-- is going
to go to the bromine
than it's going to
go to the carbon.
So the way that this reaction
works-- and it's really
kind of happening in one step.
And this is key to the
name of this reaction,
as we'll see in a second-- is
that this nucleophile right
over here might say, hey,
I got this extra charge.
Let me share some of that
charge with a nucleus--
in this case, the carbon.
Let me draw it like this.
So it would share this pair,
which would form a bond.
Carbon would have
half of the pair.
Oxygen would have
So it would share
this pair with carbon.
Now, if carbon is now
sharing half of this,
it's essentially kind
of getting an electron.
It doesn't need this electron,
which bromine is already
hogging a little bit.
And so bromine would take
this entire pair back.
Whenever we draw full arrows
like this-- just normal arrows
that you're used
to seeing-- it's
referring to the
action of pairs.
So this whole pair
is going to bromine.
This pair right over
here is now going
to be shared with the carbon.
It's going to form a
bond with the carbon.
So when we do both
of these steps,
after both of these steps,
it would look like this.
Let me draw my
bromine first, which
is now going to become
a bromide anion.
So bromine one, two,
three, four, five, six.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
And now, it gets both of these
electrons from this bond.
So it has both of those
electrons right over there.
Now, this will have
a negative 1 charge.
How do we know that?
Well, bromine is neutral, but
it has seven valence electrons.
And this thing now has eight.
So this now has a
negative charge.
Now, let's think
about what happens
to all of this business.
So let me draw my carbon first.
And let me draw this
hydrogen that's popping out.
So this hydrogen that's popping
out, let me draw it like that.
So that's the bond.
I'm trying to show that's
popping out of the page.
So that's that hydrogen.
I just made them
different colors
so we can keep track of
the different hydrogens.
Then the hydrogen that's
going into the page, that's
that one right over there.
And you have this
hydrogen that's going up.
So that hydrogen
right over there.
And now, the hydroxide anion
has bonded to this carbon.
Now it'll be a hydroxyl group.
So this thing has now bonded.
So let me draw the bond and the
color of these two electrons.
It has now bonded.
So those two electrons
now make up this blur,
this bond right over here.
And now, we have our
oxygen but with those two,
these two right over here,
and then, the bond
to the hydrogen.
Now, what just happened here?
The oxygen is now neutral.
Why is it neutral?
Well, it has one,
two, three, four.
And then, it has
half of this bond.
So you could view
that as an electron
or the equivalent
of electron charge.
And then, it has
half of this bond.
So it has the electron
charge equivalent
of six valence
electrons-- which makes
oxygen neutral-- and
now bromine is negative.
So one way to think about it
is that the negative charge
has been transferred to the
bromine in this reaction.
Now, in this reaction,
bromine has left.
And that's why we call this the
leaving group of the reaction.
This thing right over
here is the thing
that is going to leave.
That is the leaving group.
Now, the other thing that you
might find interesting-- it
looks like kind of
this hydroxide anion.
Some people would even say
attacked this bromomethane,
the bromomethane left.
The bromine left-- not
the bromomethane left--
that attacked the
bromomethane, the bromine left.
So in some ways, you would
say that there's really
two reactants over here.
You have the hydroxide anion,
and you have the bromide anion.
And this carbon right over
here with the hydrogens,
this was kind of the
thing that to some degree
facilitated the reaction.
This thing bumped
into it and attached.
And then, this thing the left.
And so in this context,
we would call the carbon--
with the three hydrogens-- we
would call this the substrate.
Now, what should we
call this reaction?
Well, one way to think about
it is we substituted this bromo
group with a hydroxyl group.
So it might make sense to call
this a substitution reaction.
Substitution has occurred.
Now, what did we
substitute with?
Well, we substituted
with a nucleophile.
And how many reactants
were involved
in the rate-determining step?
And I know that might not
make a lot of sense to you.
But this had, essentially,
one determining step.
This had to want to
bump in the right way.
And this would want to have to
leave right at the same time,
or roughly the
same time, in order
for this reaction to occur.
So this reactant
and this reactant
were involved in
figuring out, well,
how fast is this
reaction going to happen?
And we're going to see
future reactions where
you don't have both
reactants involved
in the rate-determining step.
We'll see only one
reactant involved
in the rate-determining step.
But I'll just write
this right over here,
2 reactants in
rate-determining step.
There's a garbage truck outside.
OK.
I think the garbage
truck has left now.
Safe to resume.
So as we were saying, there
are two reactants involved
in the rate-determining step.
And so the shorthand
for this reaction
is to call it an Sn2 reaction.
It's substitution with
a nucleophile where
both reactants are involved
in the rate-determining step.